Okay, that's a good introduction to indexes, but there is more and
in the section we will cover composite indexes. Remember the single property
index we looked at, that had the city as to value. A single property index is
also called a built-in index. Data store can in many cases combine results
from different built in indexes to provide a response to a query, but there
are cases where this is not possible. That's when we need a composite index.
In fact we have already used composite indexes in conference central for
this query. Retrieve all conferences, filter by city and topic. And
sort by name. This is a composite index, because the built in indexes for city,
topic, and name, cannot be combined to generate the result. For this to work,
an index table consisting of multiple values and combination must be created.
This is exactly what a composite index is. So how are composite indexes built?
There are two different ways. The first way is to add an index to an index file.
[UNKNOWN] a little bit differently depending on which language you use, so
you will see how to do this in one of the exercises. The other way is to
actually run your application locally on your development server. In this case,
if App Engine encounters a query that requires the composite index,
it will automatically update the index file.
When you later deploy App Engine, this index file will be uploaded as well.
So it will also exist when executing on App Engine. All right, it's time for
an exercise where you will explore composite indexes